the Joe Rogan experience yeah some dudes
still rock Cologne I work alone heavy
like it I know I get it from burdock
good man I get this stuff see I grew up
it was a lot of pimps around the
neighborhood and they wore the best
Cologne
them dudes was sharp or they have heavy
shiny like this so when I got old that's
what I would do I get the Cologne like
this maggot yourself with it yes pimp
used to crack me up but it would be so
sharp yeah shoes be so shiny and they
get that Cologne I've never smelled me
talk to me I'm broke I got about three
cents in my pocket and holes on the
bottom of my shoes and then fellas yeah
he's gonna be all right one day just
hang out you keep doing what you don't
keep them what you doing oh boy give see
pimps up hoes down yeah yeah yeah not
even a real life oh yeah weird it is up
it isn't some clowns they like clowns
they're who get together and they Stace
what they do that's what and that's
where you live
nice beer and 12 Street you know what
you don't want to Detroit you do you
know black bottom they call my place
called black bottom Hastings Street all
pimps and hoes they animal hats on and
they didn't have back then they didn't
have high issues you know Detroit was
booming right oh yeah Detroit fell off
quicker than any city in the Western
world yeah in terms of like it was with
the richest city in the world the ride
of the the car Motor City yeah because
the people the fact amis clothes yeah
and then in fact was close people had
put their money into the house to car
factory money yeah I get that long see
because you got then you've been a hit
15 years you got a good record you got a
good play stable they give you a car and
give you an ax and a home but when
that's like a fail boy people oh my god
what am I gonna do
what am I gonna do what caused it do you
know I mean now we say move
manufacturing moving to Mexico and other
than all that stuff yes all that stuff
people have better than everybody before
themselves yeah
but the motors forward before them sales
but a lot of companies are still there
it's just the but like a lot of car
companies you know I forward R in
general not like it used to be GM right
yeah but they're much more limited yeah
roll but it's like the what like the
base or kind of like the warehouse or
maybe they move that to maybe they're
you know that show Top Gear yeah they do
a new show called the Grand Tour they do
it on Amazon and they did one episode
where they went to Detroit and they were
in Detroit a bought a house for like two
grand
oh yeah you get a whole house $2,000
[ __ ] the whole house like a house
house that's great like you could live
in it like yeah oh yeah wasn't a bad
house we need some work they're shutting
everybody move but nobody there
everybody's gone it was the the when we
were there when we drove through is like
the amount of giant warehouses that are
completely empty with all the shattered
windows it's very depressing and it's
very weird it's coming back now well yes
so like I was there two months ago my
brother had died I went to his funeral
and we've drove around I'm backin fat my
grandfather's house they told that [ __ ]
you know they had somebody burned it
down some stuff like that I mean it was
it was just like any other city to me
it's coming back for sure but it's also
like you know there's a lot of young
businesses are starting up and yeah
craft businesses and you know when
there's enough people around people have
ingenuity they figure out a way it's
just not gonna be what it used to be
yeah been and it's a whole new ballgame
now and it's already it is a new
ballgame
new people these people are young my son
wasn't him Alex Alex his how old is he
23 23 he love Detroit he never seen this
man downtown Detroit on Saturday night
warm hot night people walking around
these beautiful women walking around
here know it my son went crazy
oi
[Applause]